continue d'en parler un de cette
manifestation des gibiers jaune avec
justement un gilet jaune jacques millon
on le retrouve tout de suite
j'admire bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt pense alors on
vient de le voir il ya du monde à cette
manifestation
quelle lecture en faites vous
bonjour merci de m'avoir invité et de me
laisser la parole bah ça fait chaud au
coeur ça fait chaud au coeur de voir
beaucoup de personnes dehors ce qui
m'attriste un petit peu c'est que
malheureusement on dit anniversaire des
gilets jaunes mais un anniversaire c'est
quelque chose de gai c'est là où il ya
des surprises des cadeaux mais
malheureusement en trois ans on voit
qu'on a eu aucun cadeau que monsieur
mâcon n'a fait aucun cadeau aux français
donc ce qu'on peut regretter c'est que
bâle pendant le long de ces trois ans en
fait rien n'a été réglé et même ça a
empiré comme disait cette manifestante
que l'on a pu entendre alors cela fait
trois ans qu'elle né le mouvement des
gilets jaunes et les revendications
restent les mêmes de ce qu'on le
rappelle un mouvement mené par rapport
enfin pour dénoncer la hausse des prix
du carburant le prélat pompe aujourd'hui
presque aussi cher qu'il ya trois ans
tout à fait je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce que vous venez de dire c'est que
le prix à la pompe est même plus cher
qu'en 2018 non seulement ça mais aussi
le prix de la vie de tous les jours que
ce soit le gaz que ça soit l'électricité
et même les produits de première
nécessité qui
à qui profites nu qui continuent de
grimper mais malheureusement les
salaires eux n'augmentent pas et donc on
est on est pire qu'en 2018 enfin je fais
un petit peu un constat puisque je parle
avec beaucoup de personnes et on est
pire qu'en 2018 donc là les périodes de
fêtes vont arriver je me demande comment
les français vont réussir à mettre des
cadeaux au pied du sapin pour pour leurs
enfants ou petits enfants ou pour leurs
membres de leur famille c'est quand même
très triste tout ça est selon-vous
emmanuel macron n'a strictement rien
fait depuis la naissance de votre
mouvement
écoutez le constat il est là c'est que
il a essayé d'apporter une réponse avec
le grand débat ou est-ce que ça en est
les cahiers de doléances sont devenus
quoi on se le demande il n'y a toujours
pas eu de synthèse il n'y a rien eu de
fait il a essayé de faire une convention
citoyenne qu'est ce que ça a donné rien
il a commis une prime de 1000 euros ça a
été fait une fois et c'était selon les
entreprises qui voulait instaurer et
dernièrement il a voulu mettre 100 euros
et ses îles ont été débouté de cette
demande là donc on voit très bien que
rien n'a été fait et quand on nous dit
que il ya eu des aides de fait par
rapport à la crise sanitaire ce n'est
pas des aides puisque ce sont nous qui
payons c est de là donc j'appelle pas ça
une aide alors on a entendu à tout à
l'heure choisie de bouche qui dit ne
plus rien attendre des politiques c'est
votre cas
oui je pense que la majorité des
français sont désabusés par par tous et
c'est parti politique qu'il soit de
gauche de droite d'extrême gauche
d'extrême droite parce qu'on sait très
bien que ils sont ils t'ont ils sont
tous copains copines vulgairement ils
mangent tous dans la même gamelle donc
ces mensonges après mensonges et c'est
vrai que tous les partis politiques on
se retrouve plus dans ces parties là et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a à ce qui a
créé un petit peu ce mouvement d gilet
jaune ce qui a attiré beaucoup de gens
c'était sortez dehors sans étiquette
syndicale ni politique et est ce qui est
toujours le cas à l'heure actuelle alors
c'est vrai que peut-être qu'il y aura
moins de monde qu'en 2018 mais ça
s'explique par la répression ça
s'explique par les amendes parce qu'ils
ont été condamnés aussi parce qu'il faut
savoir qu'il ya eu beaucoup de deux
condamnations et ça et ça continue il ya
encore une manifestante qui a été
interpellé tout à l'heure juste parce
que la fresque sur son camion ne ne
plaisait pas du tout donc on voit que
c'est disproportionné oui justement
peut-être un mot très rapidement on
arrivait à la fin de cette interview
concernant la gestion par les forces de
l'ordre de cette manifestation
d'aujourd'hui à paris je trouve que
c'est très dommage parce que encore une
fois
c'est vraiment le dernier rempart entre
le gouvernement et nous et ils sont
vraiment entre le marteau et l'enclume
et au lieu de régler ça avec des mesures
concrètes on nous envoie la police qui
font leur métier comme ils peuvent il
n'y a pas que des mauvais éléments dans
la police mais je trouve qu encore une
fois le gouvernement se sert de la
police comme bouclier voilà et c'est et
ceux qui font les frais du désespoir et
de l'énervement bad et des français qui
attendent une réponse et des mesures
concrètes j'admire vous êtes un gilet
jaune merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et d'avoir été en direct avec
mon frère tu es france merci à vous